hello hello Bill Nye the Science Guy
here sitting in for Neil deGrasse Tyson
I'm your guest host for this week's star
talk radio and our guest this week
everybody is none other than Chuck nice
hey how are you bill well now that I'm
here with you I'm fabulous
you know what bill you had me at I'm
Bill Nye so uh it's great to see you
it's great to of course the word see is
something you have to imagine on the
radio the most visual medium but my
understanding chuck yes is you have some
questions that our listeners have
provided absolutely this is what we call
our cosmic queries and you do not know
the questions I have them here in front
of me on my little tablet mama I'm
feeling the drum and what we do here is
we just allow our listeners to submit
any question that they would like and
when I say any I mean indeed any I
believe you understanding now these
these questions are submitted on the
electronic internet on those computer
machines in kids and so they've not only
you got a Twitter handle
yes got it you have a photo you're sort
of visual oh you know what's funny is
this is the first time I've actually
used my tablet to access the questions
which means that I am able to see not
only the questions but I'm able to see
the Twitter handle their profile
pictures some of them are coming in from
Google+ some of them from Facebook so I
have either an avatar or a picture of
the person who's asking me the question
you have a picture that they've chosen
to send yes a picture like I'm pretty
sure this cat didn't ask our first
question depends
you never know a cosmic cat yes so try
the first question all right let's jump
right into this bill this one is from
Google+ oh and this is Michelle Rivera
and Rochelle when Michelle wants to know
this what's the closest that any comment
has come to earth and what was it named
and when did it come close
also what's your favorite ice cream
well we'll finish with the ice cream
but I think that my understanding the
closest comet would have been comet
Holly Comet Holly yeah back in 1910
I believe it people that you could read
at night by the light revival night of
the comet
yeah so it is reported and so then you
could argue if you want to which is fun
that perhaps the impact or that became
the Chelyabinsk bolide the glowing thing
in the sky over Russia last year or
maybe you could say what about the
Tunguska event blowing down trees for
hundreds of kilometers in every
direction that's coming real close I
know let's let's go back to that one
okay cuz the other stuff I've heard now
go back to ten dusk
Tunguska ten gust I was a party 1908
June 30th is reckoned in the modern
calendar okay you know back then even
Russia they because of their history or
historical affiliations with certain
certain religious organizations they
didn't agree on what calendar to use but
in a modern calendar is the 30th of June
1908 something hits the Earth's
atmosphere so hard how hard did it hit
so hard that it blew up knocked down
trees hundreds of kilometres on just
like shows you the shockwave yeah
only more so and I remind you last year
in Chelyabinsk every there's so much
insurance fraud how much insurance
insurance fraud is there there's so much
people have dashboard cameras right
that's correct car so there were dozens
hundreds of videos of this thing
streaking through the sky everybody runs
up to the window to watch it and then
three minutes later whack the sonic
booms hit the ground yeah and all the
windows shattered and yeah you had a lot
of documentation because you're right
everybody does you know there was one
more part of that then that here's the
other part what's your favorite ice
creates vanilla vanilla is genius and
people say vanilla is boring I go you
kidding vanilla is it's perfect it's a
perfect flavor it doesn't get any better
than vanilla not for me
right and you know most flavors and
nothing but vanilla with something added
to my point that is about to bring up my
point what is strawberry ice cream
just vanilla with strawberries well then
we're just for know I got a remind okay
careful there please by no means did I
mean to diminish vanilla I'm not gonna
get an official fight in the ice cream
flavor bar if you want to enjoy your
chocolate chocolate chip if you want
your mint chocolate chip if you want
your peppermint stick knock yourselves
out okay cuz that's more for me yeah
that's more vanilla for me alright
fantastic man let's move on and let's
grab another question here and this one
is from he calls himself Red King
alright coming to us from Google mr. Nye
which occupation would best fit for a
student majoring in aeronautical
engineering and minoring in music theory
what a weird and not weird combination
at all well depends what you want to do
if you really dig rockets right I got to
point out that the biggest the biggest
mm a significant problem in rocket
launching are the acoustic waves the
acoustic energy in the flame tunnel the
flame duct okay
and so to me acoustics and sound music
theory are related intimately are smooch
applying so I'm I encourage you to buy
smooch affine alumni banach twitch I
recommend that you pursue aerospace
professionally and you keep playing
music for kicks because we need you we
want you to take us this red what's his
name red Red King Red King Red King we
and I say he Red King he or she want you
to take us to to Mars
what wrecking is a guy well says a guy
who has a guy it's a male designation
King yeah you know Red Queen could go
either way dad you said it yes I'm glad
you said teat I did hey okay there's
anything wrong with you still you start
I did started please you know what
that's quite all right there's no goalie
okay let's lunge line there you go let's
move on to Aaron W
they are known on our area ER ing Rin
Aaron W and Aaron wants to know this
what if any is the best way to present
scientific fact in the way that won't
make people super defensive I'm thinking
specifically of anti vaccination crowd
but anyone can have a rational beat
beliefs and fake science basically how
do you tell you not get people peeled
well in the face of science fact the
thing about vaccinations is they are
proven to work everybody enjoys his or
her pasteurized milk and the other thing
to remember not only our vaccinations
designed to protect your kid from
diseases but they're they're designed to
protect my kids from your kids right
vaccinations work so that this one
well-known woman got confused that her
kid got was diagnosed with a attention
deficit disorder about the same time he
or she got a vaccination is spurious is
wrong is scientifically inaccurate and I
hope her views are discredited soon well
said meanwhile Chuck will be back after
this
and you know what's cool Chuck what
slow-mo even cooler super slow-mo head
over to G's YouTube channel and get a
look at what gzip - with their super
hydrophobic materials and watch what it
looks like when a t-1000 gets built
that's right w w youtube.com slash GE
that's it
welcome back welcome back to star talk
radio Bill Nighy here guest hosting for
my beloved good buddy Neil deGrasse
Tyson and I'm here being interrogated by
none other than Chuck nice who's got
your questions submitted on that
electronic computer internet with the
electric computer machines that the kids
using and he can see your avatar yes for
the first time when you when you put in
a question we know what you want to look
like that's right we know who you are
now and we actually know who Mark
Siegert is and or psychic I'm not
particularly sure don't want to mess
that up mark but he's got a pretty cool
question here for you bill with the
majority of stars in the universe
the majority of stars that's what he
says the majority of stars in the
universe being red dwarfs and the
majority of planets revolving around red
dwarfs is there any chance of life on
those particular planets and if yes will
it be completely different will plants
or microorganisms be able to use the
much weaker solar energy so a different
take on photosynthesis basically would
there be I say that have to be okay
that's what I would say and and the
reason I would say that is there's so
many stars when people throw around the
expression billions and then billions
and billions it's really beyond
imagining for most people now you know
when I was young it people speculated
that there would be a planet around
every hundred stars one in a hundred
stars just one planet for every hundred
stars then of those how many of those
would be earth-like you take another
fraction well it turns out Kepler space
telescope Hubble Space Telescope right
apparently every star is a star system
right
with planets now why would you know why
would just a quick aside why would the
assumption be made that one planet for
every hundred stars when our Sun is a
star and we clearly have eight planets
around our so we were just that we were
just dealing with it man
nobody knew you didn't have a Kepler
space telescope you were jamming I'm
talking about Frank Drake and Carl Sagan
and our cantar predecessor predecessors
okay go ahead so continue the chances of
there not being life when you have
billions of planets just it seems
extraordinarily low that is to say the
chance of there not being anything just
got to be vanishingly small there has to
be something out there absolutely just
because we have green plants which
reflect green light mysteriously that
doesn't mean somebody else who hasn't
had asteroid impacts you didn't have all
this sulphur or whatever the heck
cadmium whatever else we might have on
the Iridium right after the impact from
the kill the ancient dinosaur who knows
what plants came up with or what living
things came up with there's got to be
something out there and if you meet
somebody who says he or she has never
wondered if there's anything out there
they're lying they're lying they're
lying just straight we already know we
don't need a test we just know you're a
liar so you know what if I ever
encounter anyone who says I've never
really thought about it I'm just gonna
call him a bald-faced liar right yeah
right out just but also I not trust you
about all right so that's cool so there
you have it what a great answer because
it yes and yes there ought to be no be
life there and are those organisms out
there wondering about you and me now
that's a different story
I and wouldn't they wonder the same
things where did we come from are we
alone those two questions maybe they're
not wondering maybe they already know
the answers could be Chuck that's not my
strongest material thank you that was
validation oh I like it
I like your silly and I didn't know that
about you it's all looks aren't
everything
all right let's uh let's move on and get
to Richard molar and Brett sure rich
more Richard molar is uh what's his
avatar look like I'd tell you my
business you know what here's it looks
like an accountant what is it nope I
tell you Ria's is a family man he's in
the picture with his son or a child I
was gonna say a child because I have my
best made assumptions with facts not in
evidence so it's right he is he is with
the child not your kid none of your kids
not my kid yeah yeah clearly yeah I
don't take pictures with my kids so that
you know of yeah all right so here's
what Richard wants to know since people
at the equator go faster relative to
people closer to the poles yeah do they
age more slowly it seems to me I've done
this calculation in physics class for
real yeah okay and it's they do but it's
not it's not much
so it's insignificant oh it's
insignificant for sure but when you get
into these thousands of billionths
things do not add up right got you but
it's a cool question an astronauts age
ever so slightly more slowly than you
and I do just by being up there by being
in orbit but being in orbit okay
fantastic of the very near future if we
can use this term or go into where the
sky is dark 100 kilometers the the
Karman limit the Karman limit they're
going to go up and down without going in
orbit they will be slightly younger oh
by the way when you're in a jet airplane
flying around the continent around the
world you're going your time is passing
ever so slightly more so slightly more
slow and for those of you who take
physics and have not computed that I
encourage you to do that because it's
fun and then the other thing that's just
used to Rivet me was there was a
question what is the attraction but and
then in parentheses gravitational
between a 70 kilogram boy and a 60
kilogram girl in parentheses
gravitational
boy that was a titillating science
problem right there the jig
gravitational constant times mass one
mass two over the distance between them
squared and that's gravitational because
the other computation is subs
I am shocked absolutely shocked and I'm
fascinated absolutely
all right let's move on to var Dan
narrows a no man I'm gonna just to do
your bed pardon I'm really sorry that
I'm about to butcher unit you're not a
native speaker of Hindi or or do right
so it's a NASA reti on that's a read on
as a ret VAR d is our buddy
that's right yeah so uh what is the best
way to utilize an asteroid deflecting
tech without actually having to use a
spacecraft if possible like something a
space station on the moon that will
deflect asteroids they'll maybe a
tractor beam some attractor some type of
similar texture so it is already just
kind of it here is my jamming watch it
too much start record is this I don't
think you can watch too much Star Trek
that's so true but right about that I've
tried I haven't I'm having overdosed yet
the thing I'm fine I could quit if I
wanted that is as soon as you say we're
going to have something on the moon to
deflect it that's going to involve a
spacecraft yeah so they're correct the
questions trick Olli worded but I think
having a tractor beam is technology
beyond us right now
however you may recall Tom Swift and his
rep electron Skyway
Tom Swift jr. he had repelled at Ron's
which would be beams that would repel
objects instead of that taking it one
step less farther into the future you
could use earth or moon based lasers to
zap the asteroid if you could find it
and aim it with such precision and keep
the beam narrow enough and cause the
material on the asteroid to volatize to
blades to burn off right to eject and
then the momentum of the ejected
material fabulous Latin word the ejecta
would then have you potentially
hypothetically imagination Li would have
enough momentum to deflect the asteroid
we only need to change typical asteroid
might be going 20 kilometers a second
20 kilometres a second and we got to
deflect at about two millimeters a
second about a 10 millionth of its
momentum a 10 millionth of its Delta of
its V has to be changed of its velocity
and Direction speed and direction has to
be changed so this is uh that's not a
bad insightful thoughtful insight
however the problem is going to be an
international one just finding the
asteroids is a huge deal and it is Chuck
yes only as far as anybody can reckon
the only preventable natural disaster I
am delighted that var teased out their
thinking about this no madam party is
doing a great job to go get up so you're
saying basically it would be more is it
more feasible to repulse than it is to
guide yeah okay so uh but still great
that you like they're they're a Co
interrelated together between themselves
I got you that is to say puns intended
in that deflecting one is going to
involve changing its velocity changing
its speed and direction somehow when you
smack into it or you get something with
mutual gravity to tow it off course
right or what we at the Planetary
Society are all hot for is volatize
ngosource pace based lasers awesome
laser be spacecraft I gotta tell you
that's the first time I've ever heard
that and I think it's fantastic that's
good you keep thinking about that and
we'll be back right after this welcome
back Bill Nye here guest hosting OnStar
talk radio for my beloved buddy Neil
deGrasse Tyson I don't want you all to
be jealous but I'm sitting here with
Chuck nice Oh bill eat your hearts out
people but you can join us bye bye audio
bye sound cuz Chuck has some thoughtful
insights that you have provided him that
is to say some questions that's right
Mick
so we're cosmic queries and we have
taken questions from all over the
internet whatever source that we are a
part of and Alice as far as you know as
far as we know all of these questions
yes all over the internet all over there
are from Earth is that right as far as I
know and I cannot confirm nor deny that
yes excess in my limited understanding
of where they from where they come which
would be from what I know the internet
let earth on earth that's all I know but
it could be let's move on to Madison
Barnes and Madison has also included a
picture now I'm pretty sure this is his
child because it's an infant and he's
laying on the bed with it and he looks
really happy then again by that
description maybe it's not his child I
was going to say are you associating
with that or I was just ghosting is it's
completely unrecognizable to you as a
parent as a parent you're right it's
completely unrecognizable to be so
sixteen miserable years yes there you
have it and most of them because of the
children bill I know I know they uh it's
an it's a what is it insanity is
hereditary you get it from your kids
that's just hardly all right here we go
from Madison Barnes and Madison wants to
know this finding the Higgs boson was
the LHC with the LHC was an amazing
achievement what are we looking for
next with the LHC and is there a bigger
and better accelerator being built to
succeeded Wow interest a Large Hadron
Collider as far as I know there is not
one being built if I were king of the
footage we would build a bigger one
right because these people the atom
smashing people my physics colleagues
they cannot get enough of smashing they
love smashing and they learn something
every time they smash right so what what
I guess everybody wants to do is
reproduce those results of the Higgs
boson finding which gives everything
apparently gives everything mass and
then what I want to know what we want
inside
ours is to find laws or rules or or
theories that make predictions that are
true the things they predict are true
here on earth and they're true deep in
the cosmos got to so if there's all this
dark energy and dark matter flying
around out there six times the mass of
everything we can observe well isn't
some of that stuff here and would we
find it by smashing things with even
more smashing as' perhaps and so yes I
would like to build a bigger Collider
and look deeper but this is a civilian
you know as a mechanical engineer I took
a lot of physics I know what you're
thinking did you put it back haha
no so that aside like it just seems to
me what we've see deep in the cosmos we
should observe here and I'm pitching
right now here on Startalk radio or with
a circle copyright Bill Nye darkens
Darkon particles of dark particles of
dark physics people they love they love
their particles they can't get enough of
particles they got their neutrons or
protons are they really particles or we
just imagined them that there's photons
are they really particles it is sort of
a way of thinking about things and so
maybe there are particles of dark energy
that interact with dark matter that
direct with our dark ons that interact
with everything we know and see and that
discovery would dare I say a Chuck
change the world that would change the
universe would change our understanding
of the universe it actually the universe
would remain exactly the station we know
is for us there's that right that
extraordinary chance that the we could
build a Collider big enough to change
things yes like they do when the end of
dinner movies well that was an
insightful question I have to say nice
job to sound so surprised well you know
I just cuz the guy's got a kid doesn't
mean he can't think you know what okay I
had a joke there that I certainly cannot
say well you said just cuz he's got a
kid doesn't mean he can't think but
they're saying it about you don't that's
right I'm saying it about my dad it's a
little late and apart uh here we go
let's go with you're embarrassing me dad
you've been in my house very much I've
heard tell Eric of Valdai wants to know
this bill okay so think about relativity
and how time does funny things when
something is supermassive we're moving
fast I have in my kitchen a stove and a
microwave each with a respective clock I
have synchronised the clock clocks and
after a few weeks noticed that the
microwave is running four to five
minutes faster so my question is is my
microwave moving faster or slower
through the universe or is it denser
than a stove Eric I would say neither
neither moving it pretty much exactly
the same speed through the universe but
there's different circuitry running the
clocks now back in the day this would be
three and a half years ago the power
company was required to count a number
of cycles of 60 cycle power a week
they're no longer they no longer have
that requirement although by long
tradition most power companies do so
what you're witnessing is an artifact of
the circuit design and so if we'll see
in the near future if the next
generation of these appliances has
clocks includes clocks that are
coordinated with global positioning
satellites I hope you'll think about it
because we'll be back right after this
welcome back welcome back Bill Nye here
guest hosting for my beloved Neil
deGrasse Tyson and I'm here with none
other than Chuck nice hey Bill who with
his electronic tablet machine is
wrangling your brilliant questions which
you sent to us on the Internet and I
just want to remind everybody the thing
that Chuck seems to be fascinated of
course he's fascinated with your
questions but I can tell he's looking at
your avatars with a picture I have to
tell you and this next gentleman which
is Danny 8 is tweeting to us from and
you know it's a guy yes I am
unless see unless a lot of love this
picture will reveal something quite
shocking this is a guy will get - ok ok
so Danny Danny wants to know this
gravity can affect light as in general
rel general rel general we call it ok
but can it affect strong nuclear force
or do black holes already do that black
holes certainly affect affect light
right and the strong nuclear force I
think now this is why I'm not an expert
on this I think is independent of
photons I mean that's one of its deals
light is comprised of photons and
photons can affect electron orbitals but
I don't think they can get in there to
the strong nuclear force now perhaps in
coming weeks
our beloved Neil will have a great deal
more to say about that but I think
that's photonic interactions don't
happen don't happen inside between
quarks and and baryons have any nuclear
heavy particles in atomic nuclei with
that said the stuff that goes on in
black holes is not very well understood
so maybe things are torn apart and
photons take on a new something that we
don't understand inside black holes
gotta investigate
black holes tricky business I would say
so I would say so can't see him haha
what about that flying blind huh does
that know much yeah there you go
all right Danny hey that's a there you
have it man the answer is pretty much
probably long probably not probably not
almost certainly not yeah okay all right
so uh this one is from at old man Carson
and this is Jonathan Carlson at old man
Carlson
wants to know if you want to send them
an email yeah if you want to if you want
to tweet Jonathan it's at old man
Carlson and maybe that's an old picture
because he looks like a very young man
if in the double-hole electron
experiment II goes through walls and I
made of II why can't I go through walls
uh maybe you'll be able to but making
yourself out of a is a big paralyzing
electronic electric field there's the
rug huh but once again our heroes on
Star Trek there they do it all the time
absolutely you can transport down into
uh if there's a cavern couple miles on
the ground yes yes go right there don't
bring you get there everybody will speak
perfect English exactly mazing that is
the cool thing however now that's very
funny that's true Wow they all speak
perfect English well it's a big
time-saver and when you when you're
gonna do a TV show hey guess what it's
in the United States for audiences that
are native speakers English it's the
business language of the universe people
aerospace it is for sure oh cool
know when you travel around the world go
to the Astronautical Congress and what
have you as I have yes through I speaks
English because NASA just you know and
Boeing right McDonnell Douglas just
establish this so the Wright brothers
just establish this so far back exactly
that it's going to be but who knows what
the future holds
who knows what your children will be
speaking when they've run their own
software companies that Mandarin and
Cantonese and Purdue are you hinting at
the inevitable decline
of our great empire bill no but the
developing world is developing
developing world is develop so are you
saying that we might have to learn
Cantonese or Mandarin well Cantonese it
would because Mandarin is what have you
tonal languages and so this is not a bad
thing it's a thing when you meet people
from Europe they routinely speak two or
three languages because I have to okay
and that's not neither here nor there
but you know you can drive all the way
across the country of France in six will
seven hours you drive six hours out of
here you barely get to Buffalo I was
going to say yes that was an advanced
burg yeah it's not that we're all bad
it's that the u.s. turned out to be this
huge country so do we have one more
question because the Bertha breaks
approaching I feel the excitement you
know what I'm going to give you this
question but you might have to answer it
after the break whoa whoa whoa because I
think you're gonna need some time for
this but uh this is what at Artie feely
wants to know climate change deniers
drive me crazy how can we convince them
that the data is real and not some scam
I'll tell you right after this hey Bill
Nye here guest hosting for my beloved my
good friend Neil deGrasse Tyson here on
Startalk radio I don't want you to be
jealous yes I'm here with Chuck nice and
he is all that ladies he is nice now
Chuck we had a question right before the
break
yes we did an Artie feely wanted to know
climate climate change deniers drive me
crazy how can we convince them that the
data is real and not some kind of scam
well here's the thing about the scam
conspiracy theories are lazy wouldn't it
be nice if there were someone in charge
screwing things up on purpose but
actually things are screwed up just sort
of by accident we got seven billion
people living on a planet where the
atmosphere is just is thick if you could
drive straight up on some crazy road
with some crazy car you'd be in outer
space in an hour and a half the way
people drive in New York you'd be there
and maybe quality five minutes yeah
exactly so conspiracy theories are not
very good explanations
for things especially something as
complicated as climate change I
encourage you to read the hockey stick
by Michael Mann full disclosure
paperback version I wrote the foreword
now Chuck it's time for the lightning
round yes it is you have the bell there
and what we are going to do is we are
going to zip through these questions as
quickly as possible let me remind you
this installment of the lightning round
is powered by our good friends over at
GE you should head over to their YouTube
page and take a quick look at some of
the cool things they're doing quick
right after this segment ww youtube.com
slash GE yeah right welcome back to star
talk radio Bill Nighy here your host
sitting in for Neil deGrasse Tyson and I
am here with none other - Chuck nice and
tell you what Chuck yes yes but it's
time for the lightning round yes it is
now you this is pure lightning round
that's all it is no bells and whistles
wait wait they're their bells if there
are Bell it will be bells so take it
with a cosmic query in the lightning
round Chuck and here we go
let's jump right into this with Steve ho
seed who wants to know this
I'm from Heartland Wisconsin my question
is when the New Horizons spacecraft
reaches Pluto next year what is the
mission exactly take pictures take
pictures take pictures okay record some
thermal data radiation some the science
instruments aboard but pictures pictures
that could dare I set change the world
change the world Steve I think the
answer might be pictures all right uh
Jonathan suto wants to know this bill
why do we give let NASA so little money
how did that happen if I were king of
the forest we'd give NASA more money we
at the Planetary Society getting
everyone in the cosmos to know our place
within it and advancing space science
and exploration Lobby continually to get
more money for NASA the world's largest
Space Administration so that we will
make discoveries that will not only
change the world but keep the United
States in the economic game and lead the
way not that the United States has to do
everything but space exploration is
worth the United
is good at all right next question from
I'm just gonna say Ms McNaughton because
I can't pronounce her first name and I'm
sorry miss McNaughton here we go
hi from bigging from New York here my
question is what is your opinion of
Stephen Hawkins time-travel 4th
dimention theory do you believe it is
accurate don't know it's cool to think
about though isn't it's riveting and the
fourth dimension is time everybody it's
not extraordinary thing it's it's just X
Y Z and time anta all right here we go
with Jared Reese and Jared's from
Minnesota wants to know this is it
possible and/or probable to use
gravitational lensing with a Hubble
likes telescope on the outer edge of our
solar system
what tangible benefits could there be to
do this I've heard that lensing could be
enhanced with radio pictures radio
pictures maybe wherever there's a lot of
gravity out out out there in deep space
like when you have a black hole you can
observe light and in this case radio
waves being bent by the gravity and that
can give you tremendous insight into the
whereabouts of black holes and their
nature the more spacecraft we have out
there the better as far as I'm concerned
let's fly them fly them all there you
have it all right Phillip Brinkman would
like to know this how do the
advancements in technology affect our
own evolution are we still subject to
natural selection or do humans evolve
only artificially now pS excellent job
of the debate oh thank you thank you for
the for the PostScript yes humans are
still evolving the thing is let's take
me for example
please ah no I had appendicitis I'd be
dead otherwise if I run around having
kids that means those kids might have
been not coming to existence but wait
that's part of being in a tribe as your
tribe advances culturally you have the
potential for your individuals to
advance culturally and that's evolution
could it be that if we go back in time
and talk to the ancient Egyptians who
built the pyramids and they don't get
any of our jokes wouldn't that be weird
because we've changed just in those five
thousand years
whoa nicely done
here's what Susan Minogue wants to well
we don't get any of your jokes either
bill take a Chuck Susan Verner was
though this what happens to a black hole
after it runs out of stuff to eat this
that's very unlikely so yes it remains a
very massive star sending material to
other parts of the universe that's a
good question
when the source of energy material stops
coming in people have speculated about
what happens again it shrinks and what
I'd like to do is hold that thought
Chuck till you have Neil deGrasse Tyson
here who's so into his astrophysics war
all right James less parents wants to
know this is it popular is it possible
to have binary planet systems much like
a binary star system with the
gravitational pull of the star they
orbit as with the pull of each other
make it unfeasible no no it's probably
quite feasible in fact that's a fun
physics problem there the old thing that
we are crazy for what's that three-body
problem the three-body problem okay so
the earth and the moon the moon is like
a traditional planet in a sense it's a
gravitational body orbiting the earth
and the earth and the moon are in turn
orbiting the Sun and it's nothing but
fun to consider the earth and the moon
as a system with the center of mass a
center of gravity somewhere between us
and that center of gravity is in turn
orbiting the Sun so we do it all day and
when you get Jupiter with its four
massive Galilean moons I mean that's
like a whole binary quaternary quad
quinta nary a Quentin Terry system so
yes it's possible party on nice all
right here we go what engineering hurts
from crystal what engineering hurdles
prevent us from traveling faster than
the speed of light well it's not
engineering hurdles so much as far as we
know the speed of energy is the speed of
light as far as we can tell you just
can't go any faster you start pumping in
more energy and instead of going faster
you become effectively more massive that
is to say you increase your momentum
without increasing your speed very much
it's a complicated problem
covered in my father's lifetime not that
long ago we're almost done
we are thank you for listening to
Startalk we got a fly shot ah bad guy
the science guy would look nice